Незважаючи ні на що,
українці створюють нові і нові жарти
про напад Росії і доводять,
що цю націю не перемогти!
[російською] Дорогий росіянине, ці субтитри до відео
спеціально для тебе, поки ти не вивчив українську.
[російською] Чекаємо у нас тут, в Україні.
На Україні — вже не вийде.
[російською] Друзі, треба допомагати Україні!
А ви тільки пиздите. Розумієте?
♪ Доброго вечора, ми з України! ♪
Наша армія б'ється так, що це НАТО
має подати заявку на вступ до України.
Приємно читати: російська атака на Берестейській
закінчилась у зв'язку із закінченням атакуючих.
Україна переможе.
Хотів замість нашого трамвая проїхатись.
Підарас!
Суки, НАХУЙ з УКРАЇНИ
і нашого села — баба Надя.
Збито Іл-76 над Білою Церквою, також
60 диверсантів затримано на Троєщині — ЗСУ.
[російською] Я і в мирний час на Троєщину
не заходив, на що вони сподівались?
Це десь 12 км от Штепівки
стоять дві БМПшки,
а хто такі і що вони
роблять — незрозуміло.
Танк стоїть у кюветі.
Слава Україні!
Ага, все ясно,
раз не здоровкається…
Скажи слово «паляниця».
— [російською] Не знімайте.
— А чого не знімать?
— [російською] Відеозйомка заборонена.
— Хто тобі сказав, що відеозйомка заборонена?
Конституцією України
відеозйомка дозволена.
♪ Доброго вечора, ми з України! ♪
Бандерівське смузі
для путінських друзів.
Кмітливі кияни,
побачивши підозрілих чоловіків,
спитали, як пройти
в Monobank (це «п'ять»).
Мертвому кадирівцю треба в рот покласти шматок сала.
Контрольний — щоб до раю не потрапив.
Слава Україні!
— Звідки ви?
— Київ, сам виродок із Житомирської області.
[російською] «Рідко який птах долетить до середини Дніпра»,
— Микола Гоголь, засновник Української ППО.
Поки найкращі санкції на росію
наклали наші ЗСУ.
[російською] Друзі діджеї, передайте це
всім тусовщикам Москви.
[російською]  Можливо, це буде останньою краплею
для того, щоб вийти і влаштувати революцію.
[російською]  Колумбія, Мексика, Аргентина і Афганістан
заявили про виключення Росії від наркотрафіку.
[російською] З почуттям глибокого
задоволення спостерігаю, як росіяни
[російською] дуже, блять, дорого,
дорогими боєприпасами,
[російською]  з усіма спецефектами,
прям з усією хуйнею,
[російською]  розбирають на запчастини
абсолютно пусте поле.
[російською] Я вважаю, що це геноцид
наших байбаків і польових мишей.
[російською]  Звиняйте, не можу показати,
де знаходиться, щоб не змалювали.
[Військова операція із захисту ДНР і ЛНР]
[Росія 1, прямий етер]
[російською] Військовослужбовці українських об'єднань
[Євгеній Поддубний
військовий кореспондент ВГТРК]
[російською] деякі із них здаються в полон.
[російською] Так, із Луганської народної республіки
поступає інформація,
[російською]  що особистий склад
56 окремої бригади військових сил України
[російською] викинув білий прапор і віддав
перевагу здатися в полон.
— [російською] Ви чули, що 56 бригада здалася?
— [російською] А ми тоді хто?
♪ Доброго вечора, ми з України! ♪
Відключено від SWIFT.
У росіян є одна доба, щоб звалити з України.
Бо в понеділок нам на роботу.
Перша Вовина тисяча від ЗСУ.
[російською] Ви окупанти! Ви фашисти!
Ви прийшли на нашу землю!
[російською] Якого хєра ви прийшли
зі зброєю до нас?
[російською] Хто сказав?
[російською] Візьміть насіння, покладіть сирими,
щоб хоч соняхи росли, коли ви тут ляжете!
Пароль — паляниця.
Відгук — маленьке телятко цямкало нісенітницю.
Терміново! Демонтуємо дорожні знаки
на всіх дорогах України.
Пріорітет #1— вказівні знаки, назви населених пунктів.
Зібрані знаки передаємо місцевій владі та дорожникам.
Нахуй. Знову нахуй. До росії нахуй.
— [російською] Зламались пацани. Зламались?
— [російською] Закінчилась соляра.
— [російською] Ааа. Може, відтащити назад на Росію?
Росіяни думали, що йдуть
на українську землю.
Та ми ж попереджали,
що не «НА», а «В»!
Коротше, у нас висадився десант.
По старих картах, там був ліс,
але його вирубали незаконно,
тепер там немає лісу, і їх відразу побачили і
побігли затримувати. Це аж смішно.
[російською] Шановні росіяни,
туристичне агенство «Нехуй шастать»,
[російською] або «Україна понад усе!»,
[російською] запрошує вас на
захопливі та цікаві дводенні тури
[російською]  «Побачити Київ і померти».
[російською]  Ласкаво просимо!
Ми воюємо з тими, хто не зміг
з першого разу написати літеру Z.
На цьому місці мітку, будь ласка,
не замальовуйте!
Нехай потім самі засипають землею.
— [англійською] Можете стояти без...?
— [англійською] Можете. Стояти.
[російською]  Дивись! Бачиш? Записався
в тероборону. Єбашити буду росіян. Зрозуміли?
[російською]  А ви тут пиздете тільки.
Ви хто взагалі?
— [англійською] Хто ви?
— [англійською] Ізраільські...
А! Ізраільські громадяни нормальні.
♪ Доброго вечора, ми з України! ♪